aux etats unis la faire remonter aux
années 60 elle est célèbre pour avoir
inspiré le film mississippi burning
annexes responsable du ku klux klan
vient d'être arrêté quarante ans après
pour le meurtre de trois militants des
droits civiques l'homme devenu pasteur
aujourd'hui a plaidé non coupable à
philadelphie frédéric retard il n'a
opposé aucune résistance lors de son
arrestation mais devant ce tribunal de
philadelphie
il a plaidé non coupable à 79 ans est
garé qu'il est l'ancien responsable du
ku klux klan devenu pasteur n'en reviens
pas d'être là en position d'accusé les
faits qui lui sont reprochés remontent à
plus de quarante ans c'était le 21 juin
1964 l'assassinât de trois jeunes
militants des droits civiques
un homme noir et de blanc le plus âgé
avait 24 ans un terrible fait divers qui
avait ému tous les états unis et dont
alan parker s'était inspiré pour en
faire un film
au lendemain de cette affaire sept
personnes avaient été inculpées
mais pas edgar et qui donne que l'on
voit ici à l'époque mais qui n'a jamais
été confondus ce sont de nouveaux
témoignages qui ont permis la
réouverture de l'anc est dans le
mississippi et l'arrestation du pasteur
pour la plus grande joie des familles
des victimes
c'était un meurtre et il fallait bien
qu'un jour la lumière soit faite
créée en 1865 que klux klan est une
organisation chrétienne mais secrète
elle prône la supériorité de l'homme
blanc sur l'homme noir et ses membres
n'hésitent guère à passer à l'acte de la
manière la plus violente et la plus
humiliante qui soit l'arrestation du
pasteur est un coup dur pour cette
organisation qui existe encore aux états
unis mais aussi au canada et même en
allemagne au portugal
il faut se demander ce qui est le mieux
pour le mississippi
c'est dur à dire mais c'est un coup dur
pour nier
s'il est reconnu coupable edgar et qui
donne pourrait bien terminer ses jours
en prison